la population ukrainienne titre moto
organisée nous avons tous apprécié cela
après tout les 100 ou 200 m il ya des
volontaires qui ont amené des biens de
l'eau de la nourriture pour enfants
volontaires sont là ils sont entrés
donner de la nourriture à tout le monde
de l'eau du café du lait et voire même
les pampers pour bébé de boxe public n
ya vraiment c'est organisé à 5 que
toutes les personnes qui quittent le
pays ne puisse monter de rien qui ne
puisse pas quitter le pays affamés
jusque là je n'ai pas été contacté
l'ambassade de la rdc et nous n'avons
pas de représentation diplomatique
en ukraine et avec la polio nous avons
tenté de contacter mais
l'appel n'est pas passée et après
plusieurs essais nous avons décidé de
prendre les choses en main au sol et de
nous diriger à la frontière